in the early days when you were you were
hustling what did the procrastination
look like i'd say there's two types of
procrastination it's doing non-work to
avoid work and it's doing the wrong work
to avoid work oh that's nice
and so doing non-work to avoid work is
where i would spend a lot of time on
social media and i would spend that time
on social media instead of
doing work and i would say actually
that's gotten worse over time
as i've created started creating content
on twitter and other platforms the
addiction to the dopamine hits of likes
and validation has gotten really bad bad
to the point where like i'm literally
thinking about do i want to create a
like an aaa for phone addiction the the
second type is work to avoid work and
what i mean by that is this goes back to
like how we're taught from a young age
uh and in school what it means to do
work and i think it means you're given
an assignment you do the assignment uh
you're giving a test you take the test
you create checklists you do the things
on the checklist and there's a feeling
of that felt really good to do those
things on those checklists i feel like
i've achieved what i wanted to achieve
but the issue is is that as a startup
grows and it evolves the things that you
should be spending your time on change
and they look different
than the things that you were spending
your time on perhaps six months ago and
also the things that you felt really
good about doing and so here's an
example i mean there was a period of
time
where i would spend hours a day
reaching out on linkedin to potential
uh advertisers of morning brew and i'd
do all this linkedin outreach to
hundreds of them then i would schedule
calls with them uh and i would do all of
this busy work related to outreach for
selling advertisers and it felt
productive because on my to-do list was
reach out to morning brew advertisers
schedule calls of morning brew
advertisers felt very productive and it
felt productive because the
justification in my head was
hey we need to make money as a business
through advertising this is time well
spent but as we are growing something
that became more important or became i'd
say a more important job
of me as the ceo of the business was
planning was thinking
okay where do we want the business to be
three months from now six months from
now 12 months from now and this was at a
time when we didn't have traction uh so
we didn't we didn't have the bible for
running a business
and so
what would happen would would be
what i just described to you of like
setting a strategy in the future so that
i know how i should be planning my time
today who we should be hiring today like
really important things i would never
spend time on it i would just never do
those things luckily i had a partner in
austin
where he was starting to think about
those things and he picked up the slack
there
but it was i was doing work that felt
good that i could justify was value
adding to the business to avoid the work
that really needed to be done to push
the business forward and so i would say
those are two types of procrastination
and for me what would end up happening
is i've used this term before of like
the procrastination hangover and
basically it's the feeling of after a
long day feeling shitty like feeling
this like yucky feeling of like damn i
just wasted a day
i wasted a day
because
i wasted time doing things that don't
grow me for things that if i did them
they would grow me and i wasted time on
things that are easy tasks for me to do
because i didn't have the courage or the
focus to do those hard tasks and every
time that happens and i have a
procrastination hangover i think i lose
a little bit of trust and self-belief in
myself because i haven't kept my word to
myself of doing the things that are most
important to do and growing myself hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day